very happy that you are here hi guys
welcome to Friday hurry if you don't
know if I diary the look back my weekend
vlog forum I've been very haphazard
about my vlogging I don't think that's
the correct adjective I just haven't
been very consistent in vlogging for the
last two weeks so this is more or less
just a smattering of a bunch of
different small moments that have
happened over the last two weeks before
my birthday at the end of September I
went to Toronto and I did the Just for
Laughs comedy festival I did not too
deep live in front of an audience which
is what live means with wonderful guests
Harley Morenstein if you haven't
listened to the actual live taping we
put it up on soundcloud in iTunes so
check that out links are down below it
was such a fun episode I think I laughed
harder than everyone else I was in the
audience so listen to that then went to
Greece for my birthday
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and then when I got back it was just a
bunch of random things hi fry diary so
while I was away in Greece for my
birthday vacation I read this book
called the magical art of tidying up I
think it's what it's called and it's all
about changing your life by starting
with tidying your home and decluttering
your space and the first step is to go
through your clothing and so you have to
put all the clothing you own in one
space people to go through it and this
is my progress
[Music]
okay so few hours into my tidy
I have 11 decks to drop off a donation
11:30 p.m. let's do it
why not why not but not too deep story
hello for diary it is Monday it's a very
exciting day
I just wanted to shot some stuff this
morning for an anti-bullying video which
I'm really excited for you guys to see
when I got home and there was a package
at my door from tricks and clothing
which if you don't know that shake
whorls clothing company and he sent they
sent me some clothes which I'm really
excited to show you guys cuz their
clothes are really cool and not only did
they send me clothes but they sent stuff
for goose they had seen that goose
destroyed of frisbee not long ago and so
they sent her this it's an
indestructible world's toughest
competition approved dog disc because
that thing is a monster
that's so insanely sweet oh my god thank
you but the more important thing is I
want to open the clothes and show you
guys the kind of clothes they have in
case you like them and are interested in
those kind of clothes let's see a lot of
stuff you know yeah yeah there's one
goddamn cute yeah Thank You Shay and the
family and everyone at trixin if you
guys are interested go check it out
tricks and clothing we leave this
beautiful shot dan you look like you're
behind some like alien vortex and you
can't smell it can't see you can see
like kind of legs the Rays are clearly
being abducted
Jax they're Mitchell's here hello being
classically unconfident
I'm about to shoot a video let's do it
yeah well and so tonight I am going over
to Hannah Hart's house to shoot my drunk
pumpkin 3 if you haven't seen my drunk
pumpkin 1 & 2 you should watch it I'm
not going to say it will change your
life or make your life better because it
probably won't but if you want context
on what we're going to shoot tonight go
check that out that's what's been going
on for the last two weeks um at the end
of the month mamrie Hart and I will be
doing our show this might get weird
y'all at streamcon in new york city the
links are all down below if you are in
the city the day before Halloween
October 30th at 7 p.m.
mamrie Hart and I are doing a comedy
show and you should come and see it
because my family is coming and that's
always fun to see that I'm not an alien
sent down from some robot planet I in
fact was born from humans and the show
itself should be really fun me too
are there any other things that you need
to tell you guys this isn't like hey
thanks for being hey thanks for being
cool these last couple weeks have been
me finishing my book so it's now
basically done ish uh which is very
exciting and I worked really hard on it
and I think it and it ended up being a
surprising cool thing so if you haven't
pre-ordered my new parody funny style
guide yet you should cuz it's not just
funny it's actually a really interesting
that might be a really biased
perspective on account if I wrote it I
would just like you to redux I would
like to hear your thoughts about it I'm
gonna go I'm gonna go do some
affirmations by myself before I go shoot
my drunk pumpkin 3 I don't know you love
the frisbee that tricks and team gave
you I know you tried you're already
ruining it cuz its Instructables
you're probably some